All right. Enough about these crazy contraptions. Let's go to clock.
Actually, let's go to something even better than a clock--it's called a chronometer.
And let's think, what are the necessary properties that our chronometer has to have
if it's going to be used for timekeeping device at sea.
Does our chronometer have to run forever without any external source of power.
Does it have to be periodic--what periodic means, it has some cycle that repeats itself.
If it must be periodic, does it have to isochronous as in does that cycle have to take
the exact same amount of time every single iteration.
Finally, does it have to be predictable and by predictable I mean
even if we know it's isochronous, do we know exactly how long each cycle takes.
Check whatever answers you think apply.